let's bring in bret baer to tell us more
about what we can expect to see
in the next coming hours brett hey jesse
that interview is powerful and she's
making her way this is keiv here likely
she's heading this way to levive as a
lot of the folks are trying to get out
to poland you know we've been talking
about these russian forces as they're
trying to get to keeve and we saw
russian marines
land here at the port in odessa this
force had been moving from crimea then
we had the donbass forces we had forces
coming in this way and then the forces
from belarus we talked about chernobyl
yesterday they secured that and then
they're making their way to the capital
city the real question here is how fast
is that going to happen this is keeve
and you can see this is the office of
the president we know he's in kiev
somewhere we don't know he's there but
he's somewhere this is the gostimel air
base there was a big fight yesterday
with this the russians took it over the
ukrainians took it back the russians are
now in control of it it's about 20 miles
as the crow flies from downtown our guys
in that hotel as they look north it's
the obalon district and there's a lot of
fighting
right in this area as you look at
how the russians are getting the support
they have a lot of bases one is in
belarus the other one is in belgorod and
we've been looking on the satellite at
this base it's massive attack
helicopters military trucks a field
hospital
tents just yesterday this is from
yesterday 18 attack helicopters in this
one base just over the border so the
question is how long does that take
all these red dots are air strikes or
fires
there's a lot of pushback by the
ukrainians but the russians are going to
make their way
to keeve at some point and it might be
tonight and it could get ugly jesse so
keep that map up for one second brett
it's interesting if you can just see
that this was probably in the making for
many many years if you go in and seize
the eastern provinces
then you have that push directly from
east to west and then you have crimea so
that takes care of the naval asset and
you go south to north and then you have
your puppet in belarus which brings the
hammer down hard from north to south
it's just amazing to think that he
telegraphed this thing geographically
for years and years and years
we all saw it coming
and all we have left is
sanctions
what's amazing is that he has a hundred
and ninety thousand roughly around
belarus and all around here on the
outskirts but we estimate the military
does that only about sixty thousand
seventy thousand russian troops are
inside the country currently and he
hasn't really dropped the hammer on the
air strikes as of yet there's been a lot
of them there's been more than 200 but
there's still a lot of pushback from the
ukrainians and the russians are taking
losses
so how the ukrainians fight and if this
becomes an insurgency this could be
really messy for the russians and for
putin in the long haul
absolutely and i think we have to make
it as messy as possible for as long as
possible thank you so much prep bear
we'll see you buddy hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else